A couple years ago, comet 67P held the world's
attention as humanity landed its first tiny
robot on its face.
We cheered, we hugged, we tweeted.
But… then what happened?
Howdy DNews friends and relatives, Trace here.
Back in November 2014, Comet 67P/Churyumov-Gerasimenko
got its first manmade visitor in the form
of a washing-machine-sized lander named Philae.
It was supposed to live for a month, but it
landed badly bouncing on the surface into
a shady crater.
Without sunlight, Philae had only 57 hours
until the battery died.
In that time, the scientists gathered reams
of data, which they've been analyzing over
the last year; so what have we learned?
Well, firstly, even though it was unplanned,
scientists learned something just from analyzing
the sound of Philae's bounce: comets are much
harder than previously thought! 67P is probably
made of "rock-solid ice beneath a four- to
eight-inch layer of dust."
We thought comets were soft, obviously we
were wrong.
Once it landed, Philae famously discovered
"organic" molecules like acetone, propionaldehyde,
methyl isocyanate, and formaldehyde.
They don't sound great, but formaldehyde is
implicated in the creation of ribose which
is found in DNA…
This means if a comet crashed into a planet
with the right conditions (like water, and
warmth) these molecules might help life along.
Maybe.
A major goal of the Philae/Rosetta mission
was to FIND water on this comet, and find
it they did!
Unfortunately, a paper in Science stated the
Rosetta's Spectrometer for Ion and Neutral
Analysis found the molecular makeup of 67P's
water wasn't quite right.
Here’s why: All water molecules are two
hydrogen and an oxygen, H-two-O. Here on Earth,
all water has three heavy water molecules
for every 10,000 regular water molecules.
Heavy water is also called deuterium, and
it simply has an extra neutron in its nucleus.
This is completely normal.
The water on 67P, however, has three times
the deuterium of our water.
This means the comet's water isn't compatible
with ours.
Since these ratios don't really change, this
shows comets probably didn't bring water to
Earth.
The same instrument also made the most surprising
discovery on 67P a few months later, molecular
oxygen!
Published in Nature the discovery of oxygen
was completely unexpected.
Astronomers have detected oxygen only twice
outside of our solar system, and never on
a comet.
Some scientists felt the presence of both
oxygen and hydrogen combined with ultraviolet
radiation from the sun could cause these atoms
to recombine into H-two-O and O-three: water
and Ozone!
But unfortunately, that didn't happen either.
As a comet approaches the sun, it warms and
develops a tail!
The tail is spews about 100kg (220lbs) per
second in comet material!
But unfortunately, the ratio of H2O and O2
stayed the same, showing oxygen permeated
all of 67P and wasn't combining to make water
and ozone.
Dang.
But it does indicate that comets might PREDATE
our solar system altogether!
And, remember, 67P is just one comet.
And studying which features come from the
formation of the universe and which came later
is one of the many puzzles --aside from the
presence of water, hydrogen, oxygen and all
these other molecules.
Maybe once we go to another comet with more
robots or even people, we could learn EVEN
MORE!
Look, if you have no idea how we even GOT
to this comet thing with Rosetta or Philae:
1.
I'm proud of you for sticking around, but
2.
I did a video on it.
Check
it out here.
Landing on a comet, then an asteroid, then
TO THE MOOOO---MARS!!
To M